yeah I mean I think that's really
interesting that you going back to the
first part the question how there's so
many different types of donors at you i
think as students when we walk around
campus you know over here about the
jackson institue or bass lie but we're
sterling so we hear all these big names
and we think you know only the big
donors really make a difference at Yale
I guess and it feels like that maybe I
don't know why I don't know if you have
a lot of conversations with students
sometimes but it feels like there's
maybe a little bit of a culture to
pursue monetary success to kind of like
there's this expectation that I don't
have to like give back to Yale somehow
later on or get back to the world
somehow and like what's the best way to
do that and it feels like there's a
little bit of like a pressure to kind of
be that big name donor a little bit I
hope that you can convince yourself that
there shouldn't be that pressure i think
the only thing that yell expects of you
is that you become a leader in whatever
you are going to do you know and you
know many people find their passion in
social service or something or in
environmental issues certainly we have a
lot of schools here whose alumni are not
participating in this you know Wall
Street you know kind of game look at we
have an excellent drama school I was
shocked when I learned you know how
these you know these are the best of the
best you know on you know coming actors
you know they still have to waitress
after they you know and be waiters after
they graduate you know they usually are
not could not be expected to become but
they become leaders in in the arts music
school the same nursing school you know
what would we do without the nursing
school it's an incredibly interesting
school because it's not what we think it
is it is much more influenced area you
know much more impactful on the higher
level take Forrest to end environmental
studies when you go into environmental
issues you are
not going to be one of the top earners
in the country divinity schools so you
know actually you know a lot of of the
schools and all the things we teach are
not meant to lead people to a life that
will end up with great economic reward
and so we couldn't possibly expect that
you know these big gifts would come from
there I think when feelings philanthropy
really works then everybody does
contribute what they can and what they
feel passionate about I think that would
be successful philanthropy and I tell
you one other thing in the in the crisis
you know before we started the campaign
our annual fund volunteers your class
volunteer their their biggest concern
was you know with these big numbers is
our 100 dollar gift is our you know
small contributors that going to make
any difference if we call account is it
going to do anything and I assured them
it always is important but you know the
global crisis really you know made
believers out of them because when you
have every year twenty six million
dollars that you can't spend where you
need it that's you know we need a half a
billion dollars of endowment to to
generate that so it does count it did
count and it made a huge difference
having bag